this is Startalk Amanda Clarke writes
and says if the government did have
contact why would they not share with us
I know it starts from a conspiracy
theory place but I just wonder if there
be any logical reason to keep the info
from us question yeah it's a government
hiding go ahead then tell me I mean if
you can I mean maybe if maybe I'm not
allowed to hear this are they listening
I don't know yeah um look I mean this is
this is this is exact this is a perfect
question and and you know I pointed this
out to people before you know I've asked
people like why exactly you know for the
conspiracy theorist why why is it that
the years think that people would would
be the government would make all this
and not just one government of course
we're talking an international
consortium spanning many administrations
and countries and decades to all
suppress this evidence and it just
doesn't make sense those people say well
you know it's because you know if if
people really thought that the aliens
were contacting us then you know then it
would be there'll be mass panic and of
course the the reply to that is but if
you look at polls many people already
think that aliens have contacted us so
that that's not happen so that that
explanation well there would be mass
panic no no a lot of you like as you
said you know depending on what not
what's put pole you look at between you
a quarter and a third of them already
think that so that clearly hasn't
happened they they don't have an answer
they're still going to work it there
every day you know yeah but couldn you
make the argument just because somebody
might think that it happened is very
different from being presented with hard
evidence that could that create the feel
like some people think Trump will be a
great president if he becomes president
I'd be like holy what do we do ya
know yeah well there may be something to
that I mean then it's okay to say well I
believe that it's true but if the
government were to come out tomorrow and
after all I mean Hillary said something
on a late-night talk show about this
that she was going to get to the bottom
of this I I must confess I don't
understand it because if if the the
government powers that be you can get to
the bottom of it presumably say well yes
we've actually been hot we have the
aliens freeze-dried and stacked up at
air
B of 51 if they say that in everybody
would go nonlinear but if they said no
we don't have any evidence of alien
visitation everybody say that's a
they're lying to it so I don't see how
it solves anything but supposedly if
they did do it I mean do you think that
people would be riding in the streets
were we we're not going to work today
we're going to ride in the streets
because they've got aliens no this this
is absurd I mean again they're there the
government is in no-win situation
because the thing is that that even if
the government came totally clean
tomorrow and Declassified everything and
said look here's what's going on you
know at area 51 here's you know Air
Force bases the fact is that the
conspiracy theorists wouldn't believe
them they would assume there's there's
nothing or the cover-up so and this is
inherent and of course in conspiracy
theory or thinking is it there's no way
to disprove it because anything you
offer them as counter evidence is taken
as part of the conspiracy so they're
part of the cover-up then yes there's
there there's no way to target with
these people because it's like well
anything you say so you know that and
it's this again that's one of the
problems is that you know when from the
government point of view no matter what
they say people aren't going to believe
it so you know let let them wonder
what's at area 51 who cares
yeah they don't seem to care at area 51